[Music]
addiction is compulsive behavior despite
negative consequences and it's really
important to start by defining addiction
because for a long time we really
defined it very poorly we used to think
that addiction was needing a substance
to function and what that resulted in
was that cocaine was not addictive
because cocaine does not produce
physical withdrawal that is noticeable
you may be cranky and irritable and
crave cocaine but you won't be puking
and shaking and have the classic
symptoms that you would see with alcohol
or heroin withdrawal so cocaine wasn't
addictive then crack came and we
realized that defining addiction in that
way not only harms people by telling
them that cocaine is not addictive it
also harms pain patients because people
who take opioids daily for pain will
develop physical dependence but they are
not addicted unless they have compulsive
behavior despite negative consequences
to me non drug addictions are really
really interesting because some people
have argued that drugs are addictive
because they change the brain and that
addiction results from a unique
pathology related to the particular
chemicals of the drugs it is certainly
the case that the chemistry matters but
addiction can occur completely without
any external chemicals and the reason
that that happens is that addiction is
not simply exposure to a substance
addiction is a pattern of behavior and
certain patterns of experience are
inherently addictive and gambling is a
good example of this because what
gambling does is it gives you
intermittent reinforcement and so you
know every unpredictable amount of times
you win and this is a puzzle to our
pattern-seeking brains and we keep
thinking we're gonna find a pattern and
it's gonna sort out and we're going to
understand it and we're gonna get rich
you know or we find that sort of the
constant immersion
in these ideas of you know that allow
you to escape while I got to do this I
gotta you know um is going to you know
soothe you and allow you to escape from
your life and stuff like this
I mean I think it I think gambling is
also really interesting because we've
had an enormous explosion in the
availability of gambling but we have not
had enormous explosion of gambling
addictions and again this is because the
population rate there's only a certain
percent of people who will be vulnerable
now you can make more of those people by
traumatising them and taking away their
economic you know ways of living but you
can't create them by providing more
substances or more addictive
opportunities
[Music]